[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jardin de l'État est situé à
l'extrémité de la rue de Paris il est
d'une superficie de 4 hactares et il
contient environ 450 espèces àopéatorié
dont une très grande partie présenté au
visiteurs en entrant dans le jardin de
l'État les visiteurs découvrent une
grande allée bordée des
campfriers au fond il y a le Muséum
d'histoire
naturelle à droite les bassins et puis
une rangée des des palmiers
[Musique]
Royau le jardin de l'État a été créé par
la Compagnie des Indes en
1761 dans le but d'introduire et et de
distribuer des espèces qui manquaient
dans
l'île à l'origine le jardin de l'État
c'était un jardin d'acclimatation de
naturalisation et également un jardin
expérimental le jardin de l'État est une
vitrine de notre végétation parce que en
visitant le jardin de l'État nous avons
la possibilité de pouvoir aller
découvrir notre végétation à travers
l'histoire donc les espèces qui
existante et et ceux qui ont été ramenés
de
[Musique]
l'extérieur